hey guys merry here with gamespot
presenting the mix at GDC 2069 here with
taemin and you'll be doing me metric o+
that's what people might remember metric
oh I hope to do yet you should all
remember metric oh but what's different
with plus so metric Oh came out over one
and a half year ago and was for the
PlayStation Vita and that did fairly
well as in people either really really
liked it or did it really didn't like it
that's the best space to be between hey
there was no space in between with it
was one of the others oh yeah and so now
we're trying to make it too I like four
more platforms for all the platforms
that you might have basically and make
sure that more people get a chance to
play metric oh and what's different is
that ok so we made it for the
PlayStation Vita which has these neat a
hardware features such as the gyroscope
and the camera which we use but we can't
did I use that hello Ken it's a good
platform so we like half the games is is
out and we made a whole new mechanics a
set of mechanics and puzzles of world
etc and then we totally upgraded like
the visuals because she I mean your
video screen isn't your average TV
screen so so let's take a look at these
upgraded visuals right now this is
metric 0 plus the demo which is running
on PC do you want to play a boy or a
girl I want to play as a boy
I like to be someone new when I play
games oh girl all the time you as you
progress you actually turn into
something okay that's that's sort of
interest ansel just some spoilers down
there in well you won't see too much of
that mean that that's further into the
games mm-hmm and you know this is
actually the very beginning of the game
did anyone who cited on vita they'll
probably remember these parts of it yeah
most of them yeah but they just worked
so well and there was no reason to do
differently and if we want to do
indefinitely they would have turned out
worse right so and that allowed us to
focus on the new parts of the game as
well so they could be better I don't
understand like yeah how do you how do
you get rid of like a gyros like the
motor scoping of like the Vita how do
you replace something like that well we
made just infinite totally new mechanics
uh-huh um it it's just a totally new
part of the game so that it's it's very
hard to put into words because well
there's nothing quite like a game that's
sort of being remade for a platform
which was relying heavily on that
platform exactly right um and the Vita
is such a special device because it has
those those
things that you've literally designed
the game for so this is a completely I
mean it's almost in many ways it will be
a new experience it will you're you're
having to redo a lot of these mechanics
but the basis of the game is still the
same which is in a way it's taken with a
puzzler where you are traversing the
environment and right now people who are
not familiar with Mexico can see you're
basically spanning distances to raise
this platform in order to progress and
removing left raises the platform
whereas moving right does it so you have
to find a way to keep moving left
without exactly right yeah jumping seems
to work on this one yeah so there's the
first world is all about just moving and
jumping and it may seem sort of like you
kind of do it all up with that but it's
actually and refreshing when we started
making the game how much you could do
with it right oh it's a very clean
system and that's also kind of backed up
by your visual design which is very very
clean very sim I don't want to say
simple but it's em you don't put too
much bells and whistles on it here like
you're looking at simple shapes clean
colors and shades yeah there's just not
a lot you know you guys kept it really
seamless so the most complex parts of it
are measured like the image effects
things that really set that mood within
this very very minimalistic world I mean
these minute they small and simple sort
of shapes they may give the wrong
impression sometimes so I mean these are
all infographics and info crafts are
things that we know from Excel sheets
right right like business presentations
and they tend not to be the most sexy
things to look at so we do as much work
as we can or making it more interesting
to look at and that's where I sort of
fog in the back comes in the roof like
you can see a lip right here yeah and it
almost becomes a little meditative right
because you're kind of just just
experiencing this world it doesn't seem
very punishing like it seems very clean
and in fact you're actually for this
puzzle it's kind of encouraging you to
consider kind of falling off the edge
yeah previous puzzle there we're not
talking about solutions too much because
you know it it's a puzzle game so if you
if I'm gonna show you and tell you about
all the solutions there's nothing gonna
be for you as a viewer to explore once
you get your hands on this game so I'm
just gonna casually stroll through but
dying is indeed one of the it's just not
a variable like this bridge over here it
just came out of nowhere because you you
fell you fell and your kind of
encouraging the player through this to
to try your trial NER yeah and what's
good about this game is that you're
you're letting the player experiment
without feeling punished by that which
is a really nice thing to do so everyone
should kind of feel free to well there's
really no mistakes much like a bob ross
painting this game is a happy accident
you basically just mess around and see
what works and what doesn't your own
time there are no trees in here though
no no there's no happy trees like simple
happy polygons
well this is really nice and so another
thing that we did for metric applause
was there there was a story in there
there was a premise in the game and
people didn't really get that because it
was weaved through the gameplay but
people don't tend to look at gameplay as
something that could also tell a story
not when it's sort of something there
but that's what Julian was the medium
important is that you're telling a story
through the games yeah so right we've
thought about this a lot uh-huh and
we're coming up to a piece that piece of
the game that showed gives you a little
bit more incentive to think about what
the game should be about well without
using texts I mean you've not seen any
text except personal percentages we're
trying to tell everything like both the
turtle wise and like story wise and what
you should do nothing should be set
through the text everything should be
done through animations and slowly
building up your experience and
knowledge of this world so this is new
for people for people who like a fee
diversion because oh yeah we're where we
want to make sure people thought about
the premise and considered like the
implications of what they're doing and
some people seem to be taking this robot
for on the ramp it's free for Hardware
destruction
was very interesting so you're giving us
way more incentives to think can be
thoughtful about the story behind this
game yeah and about what you're doing
because like every step you're taking is
changing the world and then there's sort
of the consequences yeah perhaps and it
goes hitting the world it goes in two
ways like the world is making you do
these things right that's something
we're playing with mmm so the give and
take of you and your impact on the world
and the world's impact on you it's
actually more about the second thing but
the first thing is more very interesting
yeah I mean I guess it's really obvious
right that we're constantly affecting
the world so the second one would be the
thing that maybe you come to terms with
said this is a new world I just entered
right there are six in total and every
world introduces a new mechanic there's
a new color scheme new new shape pattern
that's emerging music is is different
for every world which is made by palm
bomba Dutch DJ who's living in LA these
days yeah and it's also like this is
another thing that really adds to the
atmosphere in your game which is you
know it's got enough of a of a beat
where you you know we feel progression
and movement there's like a look a nice
tempo to it but it's also again very
clean very streamlined there's not a lot
of bells and whistles to it and it kind
of just really adds well that's that's
that's like on the surface but you know
behind this there's actually like a
system in which you have about 40
pioneers we're in which DJ shoes like to
mix from one store to another and there
are all these lines all these these
layers of music and we're constantly
able to sort of mix them in between and
so it looks very simple on the prawns
meant to be a seamless for the player
but maybe not in terms of how much
effort you guys couldn't know so but
usually when you I'm not trying to say
that this accomplice to myself but when
you do something right you don't notice
it yes so and this way things use the
simple it works for you willing that's
it uh God says when he meets bender
that's when you do things right yeah
people won't know you've done anything
at all it's a perfect growth right there
so it's not old puzzles some because if
he just some performing yeah if him if
we make you think like the entire town
and believe me yeah there are plenty of
times where you need to think a lot then
it just becomes sort of this drag of
puzzles so that's also something that we
are improving over with this myth with
make sure plus is that we've realized
that there was more need for these
moments of rest and in which you can
explore the world a little bit more or
sort of get a more in touch with your
character there's really a lot that we
learned of course making metro and doing
this great so it's a little improved
it's an absolutely stunning game and
it's M if it's something that a lot of
people don't have a Vita and if you've
never tried this game before this is
something that you might absolutely want
to check out and consider getting so
Timon thank you so much for showing us
metrica fluff thank you for having and
when is this officially out we don't
have a date yet but it should be in the
second quarter of this year thinking
we're very things so you feel pretty
confident about that sec recorder yeah
alright sweet well thank you very much
for showing us Mexico that was much your
Co plus you guys can expect to see that
really soon and you have a price on it
yet no that's yeah it's up in here it's
effing here it's so hard to to to be you
know of course not let people down but
still make your game well it's a
different game innocence because you're
adding a lot of your well you're adding
different mechanics to it so it is in
many ways will be a new experience roots
definitely from Tim to most people will
be okay well thank you very much for
showing that off
you